mehr fortschritt wagen unter diesem
motto nahm die ampel koalition ihrer
arbeit auf als niemand sich den krieg in
der ukraine vorstellen konnte jetzt
sagen viele der kanzler müsse mehr
kommunikation wagen sie vermissen die
erklärung seiner politik wann wird er
nach kiew reisen warum hält den
verteidigungsminister in lambrecht fest
dazu steht die russlandpolitik seiner
partei in der kritik der bundestag
streicht ex kanzler schröder als putins
freund die sonderrechte und in zwei
landtagswahlen kann die spd nicht
überzeugen der krisen kanzler wie
führungsstark ist olaf scholz unser
thema in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
manchen geht unsere unterstützung nicht
weit genug andere wiederum geht sie viel
zu weit und nahezu alle bürgerinnen und
bürger ein die sorge um den frieden in
der ukraine aber auch hier bei uns
ich will daher eines ganz deutlich sagen
einem brutal angegriffen land bei der
verteidigung zu helfen
darin gibt keine eskalation
soweit olaf scholz heute im bundestag
bei seiner regierungserklärung zum
europäischen rat ende mai darüber
sprechen wir unter anderem darf in meine
gäste vorstellen georg streiter ist bei
uns ehemaliger regierungssprecher bei
kanzlerin merkel zuvor lange jahre vor
allem als boulevard journalist bei bild
und express tätig und herzlich
willkommen stephan lamby
dokumentarfilmer er begleitet scholz
baerbock und harbeck seit anfang
dezember wieder in einer
langzeitbeobachtung wie er das schon
mehrmals auch getan hat mitregierenden
und herzlich willkommen kristina dunz
stellvertretende leiterin des
parlamentsbüros des redaktions netzwerks
deutschland eher ein d und sie war auch
viele jahre kanzler korrespondentin für
dpa und die rheinische post und herzlich
willkommen professor wolfgang schröder
politikwissenschaftler an der
universität kassel mitglied der
grundwertekommission der spd und er war
auch mal staatssekretärin
brandenburg herr llambi jetzt haben wir
heute diesen kleinen ausschnitt haben
wir eben gezeigt von seiner
regierungserklärung heute morgen als
scholz sagt für die einen ist es so
wenig für die anderen ist es zu viel was
ich tue für die ukraine ist das zeigt
dass so ein bisschen sein dilemma
eigentlich dass er das nicht ganz klar
ist wo er hin will mit seiner partei mit
seiner politik
ganz offenkundig also wenn man die
letzten wahlergebnisse in den
landtagswahlen sieht in
schleswig-holstein nordrhein-westfalen
folgen viele bürgerinnen und bürgern
nicht seinem kurs
das gesicht von olaf scholz wurde
überall plakatiert also es war schon ein
scholz wahlkampf insofern aus sicht der
bürgerinnen und bürger hat es nicht
gereicht aber
es geht hier nicht nur um wahlen es geht
ja auch immer im krieg und um die frage
wie dieser krieg zu ende geführt werden
kann und ich glaube darüber werden wir
gleich sprechen und da frage ich nicht
ob das schon die
richtige art ist die richtige methode zu
kommunizieren und sie haben ihre
eingangs moderation die bretonische
frage gestellt
reicht die kommunikation oder zu viel
kommunikation ich kann mich nicht
erinnern in 16 jahren angela merkel dass
die mal so viel kommuniziert hätte wie
olaf scholz in denen klar wie viele
jetzt paar monaten
dürfen ist ja fast jede woche ein
exklusivinterview für meinen geschmack
schon fast zu viel
weil ich finde so ein interview mit
einem regierungs chef oder chefin sollte
etwas besonderes sein
aber es gibt laufend interviews er
kommuniziert also sehr sehr viel deshalb
ist es glaube ich nicht eine frage der
quantität ja aber dann kommen wenn man
auf die qualität gesichert es ist genau
dass er streit er gibt viele interviews
er hat auch am montag in einer
fernsehsendung bei rtl mit einer
alleinerziehende mit einem flüchtling
mit einem stahlarbeiter gesprochen also
sich sozusagen mit vertretern der bürger
so zusammengesetzt er kommuniziert viel
sagt herr llambi kommuniziert er gut
da offensichtlich nicht denn ich glaube
nicht nur ich aber dass viele andere
leute auch das gefühl haben dass die
grünen regieren und man hat gar nicht
das gefühl dass olaf scholz regiert und
zu viel kommunikation ist genauso
schlecht wie zu wenig kommunikation und
bei allem was man angela merkel
vielleicht vorwerfen mag dass sie zu
wenig kommuniziert habe wenn die damals
kommuniziert hat dann hat sich
eigentlich auch jeder verstanden und
ich glaube deshalb hat sie das auch so
gemacht dass sie gesagt hat wenn ich mal
mich äußere dann ist es wie wichtig und
wenn ich mich zu viele äußere ist es
vielleicht nicht unwichtig aber es ist
thomas ist es zu wenig und dann auch
irgendwie beliebig haben sie den
eindruck dass es am anfang versucht hat
es genauso zu machen ging merkel in der
kommunikation ich glaube ja denn er ist
ja eigentlich auch so ins amt gekommen
[Musik]
gewählt worden weil die leute offenbar
eine fortsetzung von angela merkel mit
anderen mitteln haben wollten und scholz
im vergleich zu armin laschet im merkel
der merkel legte war und natürlich hatte
das versucht und es ist sicher auch im
prinzip nicht verkehrt nur die
ereignisse haben inhalt überrollt und
dann muss man eben auch mal was ändern
von uns wir haben sie empfunden heute
auch im bundestag nach dieser kritik die
es die ganze zeit gibt erklärt zu wenig
oder ob nicht gut genug wie haben sie
heute seine regierungserklärung
empfunden
olaf scholz führt vor allem an seiner
wirklich sehr sehr beeindruckenden rede
gemessen die er drei tage nach dem
russischen überfall auf die ukraine
gehalten hat am 27 februar die
sogenannte zeitenwende rede da hatte er
ja mit wirklich sehr viel kraft mit ganz
starker entschlossenheit überhaupt mit
einer überzeugenden stärke gesagt 100
milliarden sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr der tabubruch dass
deutschland waffen liefert in einem
konfliktgebiet und er ist da sehr
überzeugend sehr selbstbewusst
aufgetreten aber hatte die kraft
dahinter die inhalte zu kommunizieren
und jetzt sind drei monate seit dieser
zeitenwenden rede vergangen und man hat
das gefühl dass der schwung sich so
verflüchtigt weil er jetzt im ungefähren
bleibt weil wir eine debatte haben ja
schweres gerät soll in die ukraine
geliefert werden aber dann völlig
überraschend ein panzer der gepard den
die ukraine überhaupt nicht haben wollte
der viel komplizierter zu bedienen ist
als einmal zum beispiel für den die
munition fehlt und heute im bundestag
war dann ja die gegenrede des unions
fraktions führers oder vorsitzenden
friedrich merz der gesagt hat er treibe
ein spiel der bundeskanzler und damit
wollte er suggerieren deutschland sagt
es liefere schwere waffen macht es aber
nicht wirklich weil irgendwas fehlt und
wartet auf ein waffenstillstand
möglichst um 1 nicht zu werden teil also
eine kriegspartei zu werden die
vielleicht die aggression stärker auf
deutschland ziehen könnte und was jetzt
fehlt es einfach dass er diesen schwung
der zeitenwende rede wieder aufnehmen
der herr schröder nun sind das wirklich
sehr schwierige zeiten und wir gerade
auch für einen regierungschef der jetzt
so neu ins amt gekommen ist auch wenn er
sehr erfahren ist als minister in frau
gesagt er bleibt im ungefähren würden
sie dem zustimmen und ist es gerade auch
etwas was in so einer kriegssituation
gar nicht anders geht
also erstmal bleibt er nicht im
ungefähren weil die
vorgehensweise die er präferiert ist ja
relativ klar unterstützung für die
ukraine versuch alles zu vermeiden was
den krieg in richtung westen treiben
kann und dann sind natürlich die
zwischenschritte wie diese konkrete
unterstützung für die ukraine aussieht
die sind sicherlich im einzelnen
begründung bedürftig überprüfungs
bedürftig aber hier ist klar dass sehr
viel passiert ist in den letzten monaten
insofern müssen wir achtgeben dass wir
nicht die ganze zeit über den stil
sprechen so wir müssen ja die
entscheidung uns anschauen und die
entscheidungen sind ja mit der
regierungserklärung vom 27.02 klar
umrissen worden richtig ist dass der
schwung danach nicht mehr so erkennbar
war und dass das vor allen dingen in der
öffentlichen debatte dann auch zu
negativen konnotation geführt hat aber
scholz hat ja permanent versucht durch
die vielfältigen auftritte diese
erklärungen die ihm wichtig sind und das
heißt ein abgestimmtes vorgehen mit der
nato innerhalb der nato zum maß der
dinge zu erklären
und jetzt ist ja auch über die
landtagswahl angesprochen den drei
landtagswahlen eine landtagswahl ist
durch die spd gewonnen worden damit hat
die spd im bundesrat zucker ein
bundesland mehr auf seiner seite die
beiden landtagswahlen in nrw und
schleswig holstein sind krachend
verloren gegangen aber das sind
personenwahlen und soweit ich das aus
allen umfragen ihr sehen konnte spielte
die ukraine kaum eine rolle habe aber
alles um den ministerpräsidenten
stark involviert das ist vollkommen
richtig dass erwartet man auch von einem
bundeskanzler dessen partei die
möglichkeit hat ein bundesland zu
übernehmen das ganze ist nicht so gut
ausgegangen für die sozialdemokratie
dass es vollkommen richtig
allerdings ist auch hier zu vermerken
dass starke
landesspezifische gründe hier
ausschlaggebend sind insofern macht es
glaube ich keinen sinn war daraus jetzt
eine staatskrise zu lasten des kanzlers
und zu lasten der bundes-spd zu machen
sondern man sollte sich anschauen und
die ist durchaus
positiv und
ich wollte nur sagen von starte ich gehe
doch nicht allein ich wollte ganz
anderes nein da habe ich keine arbeit
die öffentliche lage ist ja doch so als
ginge es jetzt also um die spd alleine
sondern das ist ja nicht der fall
sondern hier geht es darum dass die
bundesrepublik ihren beitrag zur kriegs
eindämmung leistet und dass die anderen
projekte die am anfang der fortschritts
koalition stand das heißt die
energiewende dass die weiterhin
vorangetrieben werden oder sind werden
an den gründen die grünen ja auch stark
vorangetrieben und die werden bei denen
wird immer gesagt die kommunizieren so
viel besser aber bleiben wir noch mal
gerade bei eben olaf scholz und auch der
spd herrscht reiter auch die ganze
diskussion um die russlandpolitik der
spd jetzt auch die diskussion um gerhard
schröder wo heute klar gemacht wird er
kann sein ruhegehalt behalten seine
seinen personenschutz aber alles andere
sein büro soll abgewickelt werden also
färbt das ab
das glaube ich schon aus wie man es ist
die spd hat unbestritten einen russland
problem das muss man schon mal sagen
das fängt an mit steinmeier der auch
schon jetzt eingeräumt hat dass die spd
halte auch er als außenminister manches
heute anders sieht also etwas früher
gesehen hat und das ist für die spd die
ja auch also ganz traditionsgemäß ich
meine die stützen sich immer auch willy
brandt und sagen ja der hat sozusagen
die neue ostpolitik gemacht wir müssen
mit mit russland reden und wir müssen
mit denen verhandeln und wandel durch
annäherung und so weiter
da kann sich die spd ganz schwer von
trennen ja und da spielt dann auch immer
rein in diese debatte um waffen dann
meldet sich sofort der herr mützenich
nicht noch als totalen linken aus köln
kenne ja die regionsvorsitzende ja der
tut sich da der ist jetzt
fraktionsvorsitzender im bundestag und
und muss und äußert halt ständig
bedenken ja und diese bedenkenträger die
also angst davor haben dass man jetzt
sozusagen den die russen irgendwie
beunruhigt oder so etwas
führt was uns dann hinterher auf die
füße fallen könnte das geht nur durch
die ganze spd und auch frau schwesig
wollen wir da nicht vergessen die ja
also mit mit russland viel gemangelt hat
und da haben sie ein problem ist dass
lampen würden sie es auch so sehen ist
das eine sache warum es dem kanzler
vielleicht schwerer fällt ganz klar zu
kommunizieren also ich staune ein
bisschen mehr streiter dass sie das so
abtun dass leute bedenken haben
weil sie sorge haben dass in wegen
russland was auf die wie sagt man die
füße fallen kann also ich meine wir
reden über einen möglichen atomkrieg und
dass man da bedenken haben kann kann ich
gut nachvollziehen und dass man sich
entscheidung sehr schwer macht dass man
sie mit partnern in der regierung und
internationalen partnern abstimmt also
bin ich völlig in ordnung ich das
gegenteil würde mich sehr beunruhigen
und insofern finde ich auch sagen wir
die grundhaltung sich diese fragen sehr
genau zu überlegen und abzustimmen
völlig in ordnung und soll der
bundeskanzler von mir aus mit dem
vorwurf leben zu zaudern
soll er sich ein paar tage zeit nehmen
aber sich in solchen fragen nicht
treiben zu lassen finde ich völlig in
ordnung es ist ein dilemma man ja
natürlich und sie beobachten ihn ja von
außen aus nächster nähe sie drehen dort
auch und aber mit dem mit der maßgabe
dass das was sie drehen natürlich erst
später veröffentlicht wird wie sie
natürlich könnte ich jetzt davon nicht
keine interner berichten aber trotzdem
diese frage denn so wie wir olaf scholz
so wahrnehmen nehmen sie ihn auch so war
ist er der besondere der zweifler was
ist das also schauen sie sich mal den
sprachgebrauch von olaf scholz anderen
vergleichen ihnen sagen wir mit dem von
robert habeck und annalena baerbock
direkt nach dem kriegs anfang hat
annalena baerbock serie love auf ihren
amtskollegen ein lügner beschimpft das
wort würde öffentlich niemals über die
lippen von olaf scholz kommen zumindest
bislang nicht man kann es vielleicht of
record hören aber on record öffentlich
hören sie das nicht und das hat einen
guten wohl eher auch verfliegt das wird
er mit sicherheit so sehen selbst joe
biden hat putin butscher genannt ein
schlechter das macht olaf scholz nicht
und zwar aus einem sehr guten grund er
will einen kanal offen halten zwischen
berlin und moskau und mir ist es am ende
also ich will jetzt nicht olaf scholz
verteidigen aber es geht jedoch um sehr
viel mehr als um die frage der
kommunikation es geht letztlich um die
frage wie dieser krieg beendet werden
kann und ich hab noch mal nachgeschaut
wie die kubakrise jetzt vor 60 jahren
beendet wurde das stand ja die welt auch
am rande eines atomkrieges
da wurde über die ganzen tage dieser
dieses konflikts einen kanal offen
halten zwischen washington und moskau
und am ende hat der bruder von john f
kennedy mit dem service botschafter ein
geheimabkommen
vereinbart weil sie miteinander
gesprochen haben aber sie können nicht
miteinander sprechen wenn sie den
anderen lügner oder butscher nennen
deshalb diese zurückhaltung im umgang
mit von mir aus können wir journalisten
das sagen lügner kriegsverbrecher alles
in ordnung aber dass der bundeskanzler
sich mit dieser sprache zurückhält und
dann natürlich nicht so gut ankommt wie
der wirtschaftsminister und die
außenministerin ist ein dilemma aber es
hat vielleicht langfristig zur das dass
er hilft diesen krieg zu bilden aber
genau das könnte man ja auch erklären
das könnte man erklären und das ist ein
problem von uns wie sehen sie es ist es
wenn wir gerade im vergleich auch zur
annalena baerbock als außenministerin
die da viel deutlicher ist viel
emotionaler ist ist das sozusagen also
die aufteilung in der regierung weil das
so gerade dann besser sinn macht oder
entspricht es einfach beiden typen
emotional
ich hab mir gerade vorgestellt als herr
llambi erklärt hat warum over olaf
scholz das so macht da habe ich gedacht
wenn olaf scholz das mal selber so sagen
würde ich glaube die leute wären viel
näher bei ihnen man würde das dann genau
verstehen wenn man einmal sagen würde es
wird auch mal ein russland ohne putin
geben und aber ohne putin wird dieser
krieg nicht beendet das heißt es muss
irgend einen weg geben noch mit ihm zu
kommunizieren
deswegen die ansprache von herrn llambi
einmal von herrn scholz natürliches
glauben sie schon viel besser verstehen
wird gemütlich bin ich bin sowas von
breite
wollte nur sagen leicht verständliches
macht es den menschen einfach
leichter dinge nachvollziehen zu können
und zu hören streiter noch ein wort zu
den bedenken er mit sie nicht hat noch
einen zweiten weg gezeigt nämlich das ja
bedenken das stimmt aber deswegen ist ja
nicht unbedingt ein reiner putin
verstehe sondern hat gesagt neben
waffenlieferungen muss es noch etwas
anderes geben nämlich den weg der
diplomatie und es ist vermutlich und zu
befürchten es ist noch nicht die zeit
gekommen um
diplomatisch aktiv zu werden aber wir es
uns doch allen klappt es ist doch jetzt
eine binsenweisheit mit waffen wird kein
krieg beendet es wird nur über
diplomatie gehen und insofern ist es ich
hab da gerne zugehört was er müsse nicht
noch dazu zu sagen hat weil das im
moment etwas in den hintergrund kommt
sich darüber gedanken zu machen wer wird
am ende der vermittler seien in diesen
krieg wenn kiew und moskau das nicht
alleine hinbekommen er der ukrainische
botschafter hat im übrigen dass man die
format wieder ins gespräch gebracht was
ich sehr interessant fand dass er meinte
in diesem format deutschland russland
frankreich und die ukraine könnten sich
zusammensetzen dann würde man ja sagen
wenn das so wichtig ist und diplomatie
so wichtig ist dann stellt sich ja diese
ganz banale frage warum reist dann nicht
nach kiew darüber gab so viel hin und
her herr schröder wie haben sie das
empfunden und das ist hätten das ist er
wirkt ja immer abstruser jetzt hat ja
gesagt er will nicht mehr nach kiew
reisen weil er nicht ein symbolisches
foto haben will das bauwerk ist aber
doch gereist also wie haben sie das
empfunden oder warum reist er nicht
dahin
ich habe scholz als sehr
eigenständigen menschen wahrgenommen
diese situation der sich nicht drängen
lässt der keine politik aus der
drucksituation
für sich in anspruch nimmt sondern
souveränität und diese souveränität
sieht so aus dass er selbst bestimmt
wann er einen solchen besuch macht und
zweitens wenn er etwas zu sagen hat und
wenn er etwas beitragen kann aber sie
haben natürlich alle recht in der welt
der bilder in der wir leben haben die
zunächst mal einen situativen vorteil
die diesen wunsch nach bildern und damit
nach emotionalität und nach nähe
erfüllen könnten diejenigen einen
nachteil die er im
strategischen dimension mittel und
längerfristige art decken bei scholz ist
es so dass er für sich in anspruch nimmt
diese verantwortung tätiger ist dass er
einen plan hat wie das aussehen könnte
und das bedeutet immer auch nicht nur
diplomatische lösung sondern dass
russland natürlich weiter auf der
landkarte ist und dass erstens ein
frieden herbei diplomat irrt werden muss
und zweitens damit vermutlich auch ein
stück weit eine neue weltordnung und die
russen sind das zweitstärkste nukleare
land der welt insofern kann egal wie das
aussieht russland nicht sich selbst
überlassen werden sondern es muss
integriert werden und das ist die
dimension in der scholz denkt und er
lässt sich da nicht in die enge treiben
und lässt sich auch nicht vorschreiben
was er wann wie zu tun was aber dann
doch souveränität er ist souveränität
sagen sie vieles andere sagen das ist
arrogant und trotz sicher streiter wie
empfinden sie es weil es gab er dann
schon ein symbolisches foto des
brandenburger tor wurde in den farben
der ukrainische flagge angestrahlt und
er stand mit macken davor da ging man ja
extra für den fototermin hat man das ja
inszeniert aber er sagt dann er will
nicht nach kiew um ein ja für ein
symbolisches foto ja ich fand das war
ein ganz schlechtes argument da war ja
glaube ich auch ein bisschen verärgert
über die reise von friedrich merz das
hat ihnen einfach wahrscheinlich gestört
und natürlich meine alle anderen waren
auch da und auch frau bewarb war da und
ich meine das ist das was ich so
faszinierend finde im moment
dass robbie bach und herr habe sind
überall da wo eigentlich entweder
herrschers oder seine minister seien
sollten also zb frau besucht die
bayerischen staaten warum macht das
nicht mal frau lambrecht weil da gibt es
ja viel zu besprechen mit den
mit den militärs dort und da fährt sich
einfach nicht hinten und dann denkt man
sich einfach also dass das deutsche
gesicht im ausland oder
gerade im osten das sind das ist frau
bernburg und dichter chance oder jemand
anders und ich finde es gar nicht
schlecht und vielleicht hat herr scholz
ich meine kann ja auch sein dass er da
so organisiert hat dass er das möchte
vielleicht ist es gar keinen fehler von
ihnen doch einfach nicht mehr gewohnt
über das sind normalerweise der
außenminister die außenministerin das
ist bei heiko maas und angela merkel war
es eben andere kann muss ja auch nicht
alles machen nur mit dieser kreise da
muss ich mal sagen da hat er freilich
mehr als heute schon einen punkt
wo er gesagt hat dass scholz argument
man fährt er dich hin für einen
fototermin das gilt
für den un-generalsekretär also für alle
die auch schon da war ja und da sie die
verteidigerin schon angesprochen haben
und den oppositions vorsitzenden
friedrich merz da ging es heute auch um
die fragen die verteidigungsministerin
frau lambrecht und da schon mal rein wie
friedrich merz da olaf scholz attackiert
hat beim thema verteidigungsministerium
am letzten wochenende ist ein bericht in
der presse erschienen meine damen und
herren der nun endgültig belegt dass
diese ministerin das vertrauen der
soldatinnen und soldaten der bundeswehr
nicht mehr erreichen wird deswegen den
ich ihnen den rat trennen sie sich von
dieser ministerin so schnell wie möglich
sie werden ist sowieso irgendwann in den
nächsten wochen und monaten machen
müssen also machen sie dich kalt damit
es mit der bundeswehr auch wieder
wirklich voran gehen das war nur ein
thema von mehreren kritischen themen die
friedrich merz da angesprochen hat frau
dunst treibt friedrich merz oder
vollster gerade ziemlich vor sich her
er hat auf jeden fall ein punkt mit der
verteidigungsministerin weil das ist
gerade angesprochen wurden sie einfach
nicht vorkommt sie ist ja eine der
entscheidenden figuren im kabinett in
einer kriegs- und krisenlage und das web
oder womit man sie wahrnimmt sind
kleiden pech und pannen und auch zum
teil fehlendes wissen so erscheint es
zumindest und dann die wenn man jetzt
vergleicht ein land das im krieg ist wie
die ukraine und dieser dieser
zusammenhalt im land besteht und doch
eine kraft nach vorne und eine strategie
würde man sich natürlich wünschen ein
land das in frieden ist wie deutschland
aber helfen kann das seien eben neben
dem kanzler in den wirtschaftsminister
und der außenministerin die
entscheidende funktion nämlich die
verteidigungsministerin eine ganz
wichtige rolle spielt mein eindruck ist
herr scholz macht vieles mit was
eigentlich die verteidigungsministerin
machen würde für mich ist das schon ein
indiz dass er schwäche erkannt hat ich
vermute dass ihnen klar ist dass seine
entscheidung christine lambrecht zur
verteidigungsministerin zu machen eine
fehlentscheidung war christine lambrecht
hatte voll kurs aufs innenministerium
genommen gilt als da sehr versiert in
der thematik und verteidigung passt
nicht zu ihr und das merken wir auch und
das ist insgesamt für eine nation wie
deutschland in so einer lage
diffizil wendig sogar wirklich sehr
schädlich rechnen sie damit dass sie
schnell abgelöst wird jetzt
ich glaube dass es noch eine möglichkeit
gäbe dass herr scholz so etwas
hinauszögern kann es wird ja immer
spekuliert dass die innenministerin
nancy faeser vielleicht doch in hessen
zur wahl zur nächsten landtagswahl als
spitzenkandidat in also auf das
ministerpräsidenten amt kandidieren
würde dann könnte er einen ringtausch
machen könnte frau lambrecht das
innenministerium übernehmen ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass sie auf dauer wenn
dieses verbale feuer anhält aus den
medien und aus der politischen
gegnerschaft dass sie das auf dauer
durchhält und dann so konzentriert ihre
arbeit machen kann so dass sie
vielleicht sogar von selber sagen würde
das ist nicht mehr das was sie sich von
diesem amt vorgestellt hat ich halte sie
wirklich für schwer angeschlagen und
würde auch er darauf tippen sie wird
nicht die ganze legislaturperiode
verteidigungsministerin sein wie sehen
sie das also ist das eine angriffsfläche
die im märz natürlich auch genutzt hat
und man merkt ja auch dass es immer
wieder kritikern und in ganz
unterschiedlichen sachen gibt gegenüber
frau lambrecht oder ist diese kritik
ungerechtfertigt und ist da die bild
zeitung schreibt sie darin
etwas unredlich ist somit der ministerin
teilte zunächst mal die einschätzung
dass vor lambrecht aller
wahrscheinlichkeit nach nicht die
legislaturperiode in dem amt als
verteidigungsminister in überleben wird
politisch überleben wird
und dennoch ist das was friedrich merz
gefordert hat heute von olaf scholz
zumindest kurzfristig eine
arbeitsplatzgarantie für christine
lambrecht
denn wenn man den kanzler ein bisschen
beobachtet dann wird er alles tun aber
nicht der forderung des
oppositionsführers also seines
politischen gegners
mit sicherheit und würde ja dann
der forderungen des politischen gegners
nachkommen also wenn dann muss er selber
der akteur sein deshalb für den hexe
zeiten die nächsten tage erwarte ich
kein rückzug von christine lambrecht
also zumindest mich einen erzwungenen
rückzug von urlaubs und hungen aber wie
sehr schädigt das dann letztendlich dann
doch den kanzler
ja aber ich glaube das wird der mit
helmut kohl und angela merkel halten das
versucht er auszusitzen und
da gebe ich kristin hat uns recht das
ist natürlich in einer
normalen in anführungszeichen zeit
machbar aber in kriegszeiten ist das amt
der verteidigungsministerin zu wichtig
meine wir haben alle die rede des
bundeskanzlers vom 27 februar 100
milliarden sondervermögen da sind
natürlich besondere fähigkeiten gefragt
und gefordert und das stößt christine
haben weil ich ganz offenkundig an ihre
grenzen auch was die öffentliche
akzeptanz betrifft aber
so wie das im politischen berlin
gespielt wird hat das eine andere
dimension der andere ebene und das ist
das politische spiel mit dem politischen
gegner mit dem oppositionsführer dem 1 1
fallen nicht tun will man könnte auch
sagen kriegszeiten sind keine zeit für
politische spiele sollte man meinen aber
da gibt es glaube ich genügend
gegenbeispiele
dass die logik der politischen spielerei
in berlin auch in kriegszeiten nicht
ausgehebelt wird aber ich muss mal eins
sagen das kann dann kann ich mich gar
nicht zurückhalten wenn ich jetzt
verteidigungsministerin bin ja und ich
kriege sozusagen durch schreckliche
umstände 100 milliarden euro sozusagen
geschenkt ja das ist ja eine irrsinnige
summe das heißt doch aber dass ich am
nächsten tag mich hinsetze und
suche mit klugen leuten irgendwelche
pläne zu machen was mache ich jetzt mit
diesen 100 milliarden so und tag ist
nichts gar nichts kommt ja ja und
und das finde ich so verblüffend also
ich meine das ist ja wenn es nicht so
tragisch wäre wegen der umstände des
krieges ist es doch sozusagen ein
geschenk an eine ministerin ja wo sie
sich tausend gedanken machen könnte
welche welche
mängel man bei der bundeswehr hätte
abstellen kann damit wie man das
mittelfristig verplant und so weiter und
so weiter und das finde ich einfach
völlig niederschmetternd dass da gar
nichts kommt ich meine das ist jetzt
drei monate her was wäre ein
befreiungsschlag auch für den kanzler
das würde positiv auf ihn ein zahlen
wenn er jetzt sagt ich wechsele die
verteidigungsministerin aus
das weiß ich nicht so richtig also da
muss man erst mal jemand finden der das
macht der muss ja auch erstmal sich
wieder rein wachsen also ein gewinn wird
das nicht sein das ist egal wie sie es
drehen und wenden
damit ist jetzt keinen blumentopf mehr
zu gewinnen so das kann man jetzt wie
ändern dann wenn jemand andere
verteidigungsminister aber damit gewinnt
man nichts also damit gewinnt man sicher
eine eine eine intensivere bewältigung
der aufgaben dann schauen wir doch mal
danach womit könnte denn oder auch etwas
gewinnen herr schröder wird haben wir
machen ganz am anfang auch im die
landtagswahl angesprochen dem saarland
sind sie gut ausgegangen nrw schleswig
holstein nicht das wäre ein punkt wo
scholz wieder mehr zustimmung von der
bevölkerung bekommen könnte
neuer gutes regieren und das unte
regieren auch gut kommunizieren das ist
ja hier doch konsens und das ist auch in
der bevölkerung konsens da gibt es ein
defizit das ist die luft nach oben noch
sehr hoch aber keinen hehl daraus machen
dass ist also kann ich richtig also er
hat diesen spitznamen scholzomat den hat
das was wir alles aber ja wenn sie zum
beispiel mal an seine erste mai rede
denken in düsseldorf wo alle erstaunt
waren dass dieser mensch doch eine
bandbreite von
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten hat die man
in der öffentlichkeit gar nicht
zugeschrieben hat emotional kämpferisch
leidenschaftlich auch das kann er
allerdings davon auszugehen dass das im
amte des bundeskanzlers nicht immer
angemessen ist und sein punkt ist
wohlüberlegt kalkuliert entschieden und
mit vorsicht und das kann man ja sehr
deutlich in der ganzen ukraine politik
feststellen richtig ist natürlich auch
er muss schauen dass er in der lage ist
zu korrigieren also dort wo
offensichtlich
fehlentwicklungen wo die dinge nicht so
vorangetrieben werden wie ihm das selbst
auch wichtig ist und da glaube ich ist
die regierungserklärung schon die marke
da muss er auch in der lage sein seine
eigene politik zu korrigieren
das wird er allerdings und hier ist das
stichwort der souveränität wieder
wichtig und das was herr llambi eben
auch gesagt hat also die erklärung von
merz ist natürlich erstmal eine stellen
festsetzung für frau lamprecht das ist
klar und scholz wird auch mehr liefern
müssen als leute aus zu wechseln sondern
er muss in der lage sein in dieser
schwierigen gemengelagen deutschland
wieder als treibende kraft auch in
erscheinung zu bringen weil das ist
glaube ich auch ein manko in den
zurückliegenden monaten das zu sehr
reagiert wurde und zu wenig auch
proaktiv die dinge selbst gestaltet
wurden also also das wissen dass man
sich wieder ein thema und bin ich wenn
ich noch einen punkt machen darf bei
diesen ganzen fragen haben wir ein
bisschen vergessen spielen natürlich
jetzt auch die sozialen implikationen
des krieges der energieproblematik eine
wichtige rolle und da hat die regierung
ja auch versucht punkte zu setzen und
wenn die gut ankommen kann man sich auch
vorstellen dass es hier auch eine
bessere stimmungslage im land geben kann
also heißt das entlastungspaket lampe
ist und der entlastungspaket 9 euro
ticket tank rabatt all die dinge jetzt
um auf diesen erhöhen die kosten zu
reagieren glauben sie dass geht damit
stolz nach hause ist das 1 5 wo dann die
bevölkerung sagt er hat ja heute auch in
seiner regierungserklärung dazu
gesprochen wo die wo dann seine
zustimmungswerte dann wieder besser
aussehen könnten glaube das ist das was
man gemeinhin stellschrauben nimmt das
wird aber nicht reichen wenn man daran
dreht also so wie wir zweieinhalb jahre
um die pandemie gekümmert haben und alle
debatten sich darum gedreht haben drehen
sie sich jetzt alle debatten um den
krieg und es wäre jetzt zu früh aber
wenn sie fragen was kann olaf scholz aus
diesem tief bringen dann noch mal ist es
zu früh aber über kurz oder lang eine
reise nach kiew und anschließend eine
reise nach moskau also eine verhandlungs
eine vermittlungsmission
dass er sozusagen wartet auf dem auf die
zeit wenn die zeit für diplomatie wieder
richtig richtig geht ist jetzt natürlich
weil er viele fragen und nicht
abzuwarten das ist eben ausgeführt ich
glaube dass es sinnvoll ist diesen
gesprächskanal zu halten es gibt nur
wenige die das tun also mal krank dazu
gehört dazu beiden leider nicht
und dass alle irgendwann nutzen für eine
initiative zur
beendigung des krieges ist ein großes
wort aber zumindest für einen
waffenstillstand und sie denkt wenn ja
das gelesen das bedeutet doch dass eine
wenn ich
wenn ich hier an der stelle mal
intervenieren das bedeutet doch dass es
nicht um einen beliebigen auftritt von
scholz in kiew oder moskau geht sondern
es wird nur gelingen dieses umsteuern
wenn er wirklich was zu bieten hat wenn
eine neue entscheidung getroffen wird
wenn dinge vorangebracht werden weil
diese ganzen fototermine die die anderen
jetzt gemacht haben das haben die leute
in zwei wochen alles wieder vergessen
das ist kein eckpunkt für gutes regieren
und für eine weiterentwicklung der
regierungspolitik und der sicherheit in
deutschland deshalb kommt es auf den
richtigen augenblick an und auf eine
entscheidung die tragfähig ist darüber
müssen wir reden von unseren sünden sind
hier setzen wir nur die symbolpolitik
focht die allenthalben gefordert er
freut uns was denken sie könnten sie
sich das vorstellen dass das genau das
kalkül ist von olaf scholz ebenso lange
zu warten bis er sozusagen als der große
vermittler dann letzt endlich da
herauskommt
also ich würde dich wie er spürt davon
so viel souveränität des bundeskanzlers
sprechen wenn er wirklich souverän
gewesen wäre hätte er sich diesen spruch
verkniffen mit dem fototermin rein raus
für die symbolpolitik weil wir
mittlerweile alle wissen wie sehr die
ukrainische regierung genau diese
symbolfotos brauchte genauso wie der
präsident sie lenski in oliv farbenen
shirts seine video ansprachen hält
einfach um zu zeigen ich bin bei euch
ich bin hier und wir haben gesehen die
umarmung der bundeswehr außenministerin
und des außenministers der ukraine herrn
kohl über diese diese herzlichkeit und
dieses wirklich wir stehen an eurer
seite ich finde das sind sehr sehr
wichtige fotos gewesen und fand es nicht
gut dass herr scholz sich das nicht
verkneifen konnte die die
vermittlungsmission männer sie denn dann
starten sollte da meine ich heute in der
regierungserklärung so etwas so einen
kleinen hinweis gehört zu haben dass er
ganz eng den schulterschluss mit makro
suchen wird dass er eben noch mal gesagt
hat das ist die achse die europa trägt
und dann wären wir wieder beim normandie
format man erinnere sich dass die
verhandlungen in minsk immerhin damals
dazu geführt haben dass 6000
eingeschlossene ukraine eben nicht von
russland weiter überrollt wurden und es
gab die dem land viele jahre zeit etwas
zu regeln dann ist vieles schief
gegangen das stimmt aber dieser
gesprächskanal ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass herr scholz den alleine
machen wird ich weiß auch nicht ob er
kräftig oder oder machtvoll genug ist
sondern ich könnte mir vorstellen es
wird gemeinsam etwas mit frankreich und
dann wäre es allen ehren wert wenn
erwarten würde und wirklich mit einem
richtigen paket mit einem angebot käme
für verhandlungen und trotzdem muss man
dann ja nicht weiter öl ins feuer gießen
und anderen im nachhinein so ein
bisschen hinterher zu werfen das was ihr
gemacht habt ist nur symbolpolitik
trotzdem könnte man vielleicht auch das
etwas transparenter kommunizieren wie
lange das glaube ich nicht
ich glaube das kann er nicht weil er
wenn er das ankündigen würde würde er
sich selber was kaputt machen also da
glaube ich das muss wirklich in geheimen
erst mal laufen aber er könnte an
anderer stelle schweigen sagt ja auch zu
vielen anderen dingen überhaupt nichts
und dann kann er ja auch dazu mal sich
etwas zurückhalten und wie schwer ist es
oder wie sehr nehmen wir auch seine
seine kommunikation war weil eben an
seiner seite robert habeck und annalena
baerbock sind die so ganz anders
kommunizieren also das ist ja dann auch
noch einmal besonders schwere das ist
besonders schwer und da muss ich
aufpassen denn über ein punkt haben wir
noch gar nicht geredet über den hertha
war robert habeck schon gesprochen wir
sind jetzt in einer zeit wo die
energiepreise waren sie steigen so
und/oder
scholl in der regierungserklärung gesagt
wir lassen niemanden allein so wir
lassen aber zum beispiel die alle
rentner alleine und bei den soziale für
empfang aber dass auch nochmal ecken
denn ich meine es werden jetzt
irgendwann im juni juli kommen die
ganzen nebenkostenabrechnung so und dann
ist jemand der kriegt irgendwie 1000
euro vom amt bezahlt davon 500 euro
miete und soll er plötzlich 800 euro
nebenkosten nach zahlen das kann ja
nicht und da wird ganz ganz viel böses
blut hier entstehen und da muss schaut
sich ganz schnell was überlegen und
robert habeck hat das ja schon
mehrfach angesprochen also unser leben
wird sich schon ein bisschen ändern und
es wird auch irgendwie bisschen teurer
und wir müssen dann auch andere
prioritäten setzen aber jemand der kein
geld hat der kann gar keine prioritäten
setzen und da ist eine bombe die hat
glaube ich also entweder hat oder falls
sie noch nicht gesehen oder ich möchte
nicht so waren die folgen der des
ukraine krieges werden eben auch wir
stören ganz klar herr llambi ist das
etwas wo man sagt da muss der kanzler
die gesellschaft noch mal anders drauf
vorbereiten eigentlich weil es kann ja
auch sein dass es eben nichts wird mit
waffenstillstandsverhandlungen und das
ist alles viel länger dauert und dass
wir noch in einen winter kommen wo wir
große probleme
wenn wir kein gas und kein öl aus
russland gekommen
ich vermute ja
robert habeck macht das viel offensiver
als olaf scholz also auch sehr viel
ausführlicher
jetzt haben wir mal das wetter schön die
heizung sind alle runter
gedreht wir freuen uns sogar mal über
eine kalte dusche das hat sich
schlagartig ändern
und natürlich ist es sinnvoll die
bürgerinnen und bürger auf das was da
kommen wird sehr wahrscheinlich
entsprechend vorzubereiten aber sie
haben eben auch noch die frage gestellt
wie der kanzler bestehen kann gegenüber
habeck und an der länder berbalk vor
allem also mir ist aufgefallen im
wahlkampf letzten jahres haben die
presseleute die pr leute um ihn herum
ist verstanden aus dem langweiligen
scholz einen nervenstarken stolz zu
machen und ich glaube jetzt haben wir
die aufgabe aus am schaudern zögernden
scholz einen
nachdenklichen stolz zu machen also
derselbe typ ändert sich nicht aber die
das bild ändert sich das hängt natürlich
auch mit den äußeren umständen zusammen
und das ist jetzt die kunst
der politischen kommunikation
und
ich beobachte wie häufig scholz in
verschiedene formate geschickt wird ich
glaube nicht dass er die sich aussucht
sondern das sind schon seine leute aber
dann heißt er hört ja dann auch auf
seine leute und macht das ist ja noch
was macht er genau und er sagt glaube
ich auch also wenn ihr der meinung seid
dass es sinnvoll ist dann werde ich das
tun ich glaube es ist nicht damit getan
nur diese formate zu bedienen sondern es
ist vor allem die forderung
ein wenig von dem was robert habeck
kennzeichnet ein direkter ansprache an
die bevölkerung und sie haben gefragt
musste die bevölkerung vorbereitet
werden das zu leisten es reicht nicht
irgendwie in ein social media format zu
geben sondern man muss dann eine klare
ansprache machen und ja was wäre denn
dann das format das er schröder hat eben
an die erste meile wo er dann auf einmal
so ganz laut und emotional war ja das
war beeindruckend und damit war ja auch
klar es gibt den olaf scholz mindestens
zweimal also es gibt den nachdenklichen
ruhigen vielleicht langweiligen und es
gibt denen wenn man ihnen bei reisen
begleitet können dass alle die dies tun
bestätigen den völlig anderen olaf
scholz der auch ganz offen redet also
der mann muss nicht so sein dass der
jedes wort dreimal im kopf wendet bevor
er es ausspricht
man kann den olaf scholz auch ganz
anders erleben im rahmen gezeigt ja
nicht mehr von dem anderen scholz
habe versucht das immer anfangen zu
sagen ich glaube in der kriegssituation
ist es mir wichtiger wenn er auf den
kurzfristigen effekt verzichtet einen
menschen lügner oder schlechter zu
nennen um seine eigene sprache zurück zu
nehmen also das ist mir in dieser
konkreten situation ganz angenehm das
besondere ist für sie das ist in diesem
konkreten fall aber ich glaube diese
methode stößt an grenzen den anderen
politikfeldern freut uns wie erleben sie
den olaf scholz
wenn man ihnen
geschützten traum
wenn er sich im geschützten raum
bewegt dann ist glaube ich aber sowieso
jeder
spricht jeder frei ich würde gerne
nochmal auf den duktus der
regierungserklärung heute kommen das ist
ja die beste gelegenheit mit der
bevölkerung zu kommunizieren
beziehungsweise sich an sie zu richten
einer breiten öffentlichkeit zu sagen
was man möchte und ich finde dass er das
heute wieder ein stück verpasst hat und
der vergleich ist die zeitenwende rede
ende februar da haben wir gesehen wie er
das kann da war er so entschlossen und
natürlich misst man ihn jetzt daran und
da stellt sich für mich schon eine frage
warum er das nicht macht und meine
beobachtung ist dass er jetzt einfach
viel unsicherer ist er hatte ende
februar eine entscheidung getroffen das
konnte er wunderbar kommunizieren weil
er so entschieden war und jetzt
zerfasert vieles die lage wird
unübersichtlich hat man spürt auch seine
angst dass es eine eskalation geben
könnte dass es ein weltkrieg geben
könnte er hat das in interviews
angedeutet er hat das halbe land damit
irritiert und verunsichert und dann
finde ich ist er schon schuldig das zu
erklären warum er diese befürchtung hat
und eine regierungserklärung dient dazu
ein politisches handeln zu erklären und
nicht nur etwas zu erzählen und das hat
er heute versäumt und meiner ansicht
nach liegt es an unsicherheit ok steuer
würden sie das könnten sie sich das
vorstellen dass oder falls dann doch
letztendlich unsicherheit ist an sich
angesichts dieser schwierigen fragen ja
auch die sicherstellen und dir
entscheiden muss
es gibt sicherlich eine gewisse
unsicherheit alles andere wäre
unmenschlich und zeitgemäß weil diese
regierung hat ja die schlechteste
schwierigste konstellation die man sich
überhaupt vorstellen kann corona krieg
energiewende all diese dinge aber die
erklärung von frau dunns finde ich eher
unbefriedigend weil es ist nicht die
fehlende emotionalität die fehlende
ansprache an die einzelnen gruppen die
nicht gelingt es ist sicherlich ein
bisschen der kontrast der bilder mit
bierbauch und habeck was in der
öffentlichen wahrnehmung gestört aber
das ist nicht das maß an dem er sich
misst und ich glaube da ist er sehr mit
sich im reinen er hat eine idee davon
wie dieses land regiert werden soll er
hat vorstellungen wo die reformen
ansetzen sollen und er hat eine gute
idee wie sicherheit und frieden in
europa weiterentwickelt er hatte in sich
und aus dieser lage heraus kommuniziert
ok hersteller es wäre nur für männer
diese idee flecken bisschen mehr noch
allen erklären würde ich glaube da sind
wir uns einigermaßen einig vielen dank
frau dunst herr llambi herr schröder und
der streiter für das gespräch vielen
dank ihnen fürs zuschauen machen sie es
noch einen schönen abend bei phoenix bis
dahin tschüss